foreign
[Music]
it's me Dave Rubin this is the Reuben
report we are live streaming on Rumble
YouTube and locals share subscribe tap
that notification Bell if you have not
and actually if you are watching on
Rumble right now and I certainly hope
that you are watching on Rumble and or
locals and if you want to be in the
local chat right now
reubenreport.locals.com but if you are
watching on Rumble right now if you
click that join button that's right
around there somewhere you can join our
locals community directly from Rumble
and get in on all the fun I hope that
you are all doing well we are going to
just Dive Right into a big show today uh
a lot of woke lunacy a lot of stuff from
a bunch of people that are supposed to
be our intellectual and philosophical
and political leaders mostly pure
nonsense from them and then as I am one
to do we will end it in a hopeful way so
we're gonna talk about gender we're
going to talk about race we're going to
talk about climate we're going to talk
about the Border
the whole damn thing but one of the
things that I think most of you have
noticed and I certainly woke up to over
the last couple years post covered
everything else is that the expert class
right the the people who are supposed to
sort of guide us through say crises or
pandemics or political problems Wars
whatever it is the people that are sort
of the professionals the scientists the
doctors the pundit class so many of them
have just failed their basic Duty and
and I would say their basic duty is
communicating something that is true to
us so that we can figure out how to live
our lives as best we see fit I want to
show you a video uh from the
trigonometry podcast they had science
Communicator I guess that's what he
calls himself Neil deGrasse Tyson on now
Neil deGrasse Tyson
for many many years was thought of sort
of the modern day Carl Sagan right he
was taking very complex scientific ideas
and communicating them to people even
Carl Sagan's most famous book which then
became a series I think in the late 70s
Cosmos they they redid that Seth
MacFarlane redid it on Fox with Neil
deGrasse Tyson so he's kind of
ubiquitous in society as a man that
we're supposed to listen to when it
comes to science well Constantine
kissing and Francis Foster over there at
the trigonometry podcast which I'll be
doing when I'm in London next month uh
they had Neil deGrasse Tyson on to talk
about gender and sex and basically
chicks in dudes bathrooms enjoy or you
walk into a space and there's stalls
that are closed off but then you exit
the stall and you come to a communal
sink okay so it's a solvable problem
where everyone has a private space
rather than uh for themselves rather
than having a gender private space okay
that's it's solvable it's on a level by
the way let me give an example uh we
have a school from the early 20th
century in New York
and it's and I just saw it the other day
there's an entrance here and an entrance
there and this entrance says girls and
this entrance says boys it's like what
the what what what you separate
them just to enter the school I can look
back on that and say that was ridiculous
you guys what were you thinking but back
then I'm sure it made complete sense
that you're going to send the girls to
that entrance and there's an elementary
school and the boys through that
entrance okay so it is possible to look
back on whatever you were doing and say
my gosh that was really short-sighted
and look at the solution that was
proposed and implemented that was a good
idea we moved on from that all right
first off you know good old Dave tries
to give the devil his due I try not to
take cheap shots at people so I will
agree with him with the basic concept at
the end there that we sometimes look
back on things and go boy that was that
was kind of silly say uh black people
not being allowed to use the same water
fountains as white people that would be
something right but this idea that we
are going to look back and go boy we
really should have mixed those boys and
girls bathrooms quicker and we should
should have had more girls in boys
sports quicker the only way that would
be is if the woke win and they are
certainly not going to win on my watch
right I hope they're not going to win on
your watch but the fact that he's trying
to even talk about this you know we
could have separate stalls and communal
bathrooms like they are just trying to
collapse everything I would connect this
to my frustrated uh argument about the
failure of liberalism like a guy like
him he's basically a liberal but he they
just don't know when to say no you are
allowed to just say no girls cannot be
in boys bathrooms boys cannot be in
girls bathrooms locker rooms
etc etc but for some reason they want to
intellectualize it like oh we can figure
out a way to kind of make it work I was
a couple years ago we were up in uh in
Sonoma visiting some Wineries and there
was a really cool Winery I'm not I
actually think the winery itself is
spectacular so I'm not going to throw
them under the bus but they had communal
bathroom right so it was like you go
into and you all walk in together you go
to whatever stall you want and they have
sinks and I went to the bathroom
and I said this woman walked in at the
same time me and she went to the
bathroom and then we both walked out at
the same time and we just kind of looked
at each other like what are we both
doing here why are we looking at each
other right now everyone kind of knows
it's just kind of not right anyway they
just want to go down with absolutely
anything everything with this stuff no
pun intended but Constantine uh and uh
and Francis they uh they push back a bit
I I think a lot of people would have an
issue with what you're saying Neil is
because they see women being denied
opportunities they see an unfair playing
field metaphorically and literally
speaking so fix the playing field dammit
what don't don't say it's an unfair
playing field so all of a sudden the big
issue is trans women taking the slot of
a woman in an unfair playing field fix
the playing field and you know something
the day you fix that playing field this
conversation will look completely
ridiculous
that's what I'm trying to tell you so
how do you fix the playing field I'm
curious well that's hard it's it's hard
we've been through this thank you for
that question I think look if you're
advancing that is a solution I think I
have a right to ask you no it's great I
don't have a fast solution Constantine
is he's just great he's just great he's
been on the show before as I said I'll
be on their show in a couple weeks this
idea of an unfair playing field yes we
all agree there is an unfair playing
field biological boys should not be
wrestling or dunking over uh chicks like
that's just the thing the guy what's his
name should not be allowed to use his
propeller penis to beat those girls in
swimming we all agree on this so I love
the kinds of the desert how are you
going to fix it then you know he's
genuine like oh my God it's all and then
he's like
how would I how would I go about doing
that you know how you go about even the
playing field if you were born a boy you
play with the boys and you were if you
were born a girl you play with the girls
or for the point zero one percent of
people that this affects although we
extrapolate this thing out a couple
decades and it's going to be pretty much
everybody uh for the people that
genitals or neither here nor there you
got a little of everything or whatever
you're doing you have your own League
you can have your own division Connor
was with me on that one yes that's how
it's going to be dudes over here genital
whatever over here
do whatever you got to do chicks over
here that's how you do it but the
problem with these people and why we why
things seem to always get worse at least
in like the the cultural
version of all of this is we don't have
enough people who know what is right and
that are willing to say it they know
what actually is true Neil deGrasse
Tyson is not an idiot but he's trying to
like show he's trying to Virtue signals
of these people that he can come up with
something great even though we already
have the answers this and it reminded me
of a clip from a year ago now I had to
confirm uh with Phoenix beforehand that
Trevor Noah has subsequently been fired
I don't know that they called it fired
but he is no longer the host of The
Daily Show he destroyed that show
remember Jon Stewart had it for about 20
years some of you may remember I was an
intern at The Daily Show in 1999 that's
a long time ago but Jon Stewart had it
for about 20 years he stepped down and
then the show which was huge became
absolutely nothing people only showed
clips of it to basically mock Trevor
Noah but this this clip is really
interesting so again this is from about
a year ago he had a trans activist on
and watch his just absolute inability to
say what is true with any degree of
conviction as he's hearing a whole bunch
of nonsense
this issue people like to say that it's
a complicated issue and I don't actually
think it is I think it's very simple it
all boils down to do you actually think
that trans women and intersex women are
real women
and are really female or not and if you
do it's very simple just stop policing
who counts as a real woman because this
has had history of racism built into it
over the years it's not an accident that
the intersex athletes who get singled
out are women of color from the global
South because who gets singled out for
scrutiny is based on white women's
conceptions of femininity and that's
being weaponized against trans people
too so it's a fear of protecting the
fragile weak CIS white woman from the
rest of us so so
it it seems like we have discussions
about who should participate in which
category and how you know on the face of
it it seems simple as you say you know
if somebody identifies as a woman if
they're transgender they can compete
against women who are born biologically
and and then if not then not but then
there are many who would argue who are
not transphobes there are many who who
born biologically women who say but you
have an unnatural advantage over me and
that makes the sport unfair how do you
respond to that okay first off that is a
dude
you know dressed or acting as a woman
complaining that white women are the
problem so irony is dead we all get that
my issue and why I wanted to show you
this is you see how he can't just defend
what is obviously true and instead of
even him saying well I think actually
because it's fairly obvious to me if you
got that guy in a room he would say I
don't know if he has kids but he
wouldn't want his five-year-old daughter
competing against five-year-old boys
right like it's just freaking obvious
but you see he won't defend it on his
own Merit right because he's just a
servant of the machines there are people
who say that you shouldn't do this or
that also I don't know what she's
talking about about how most of the
people who have been discriminated
against have been black intersex
athletes like can I get a list on that
can you go to Black
intersexathlete.net and let me get the
full list on that we'll get it we'll see
if we can get that for you but again
it's this inability to just save there's
no such thing as black interest I love
it God bless you God bless you for
trying
good people good people uh the point of
all of this is we have a series of
people who will not say what is true and
then when you don't say what is true you
end up just saying a whole bunch of
gibberish so now I want to show you a
tweet from secretary Miguel Cardona one
of the many wonderful people here in the
United States government uh he tweeted
out this this weekend and this is
obviously in reference to the mass
Invasion the intentional Invasion that
we have going on in our Southern border
he tweeted out diversity is not a bad
word and we should be wary of anyone who
thinks it is
now he's trying to imply that if you are
saying any of the things that I say
often or anyone that you might watch
online whether it's Ben Shapiro or
Dennis Prager or Joe Rogan or anyone
who's just like awake to just watching a
mass Invasion Open Door go on in and
it's not just the right Wingers right
Robert F Kennedy Juniors et cetera et
cetera the basic way he's saying that is
oh they're talking about this and they
don't like diversity they must be racist
now he doesn't like diversity right he
doesn't like diversity of thought and
first off diversity is not good and in
and of itself right so if you were like
I'd like a diverse group of people to
sit here and decide how we should start
this country and you were like we need
some Nazis can we get a couple actual I
don't mean right you know Trump
supporters I mean can we get some legit
Nazis on we'll get to Nazis in a little
bit because Trudeau up in Canada has a
little Nazi buddy
um but like of course that's so not
sensible so diversity in and of itself
we must have all of these people and
everyone should have an equal seat at
the thing so that we can equally but no
no some things should rise to top okay
that's the point there anyway uh in that
he doesn't like diversity of thought uh
Cardona on the over the weekend was on
one of the uh one of the network news
programs and you know they are basically
propaganda outlets for the DNC and here
he is apparently not so into diversity
when it comes to that pesky diversity of
thought
there was civility
we could disagree
we could have healthy conversations
around what's best for kids I respect
differences of opinions
I don't have too much respect for people
that are misbehaving in public
and then acting as if they know what's
right for kids
you see what they're doing you see what
they're doing they're trying to make it
seem like the parents who are pushing
back against this woke nonsense whether
it's in Virginia or Florida or Cali or
anywhere else that the parents or the
bad guys the parents who get annoyed who
show up to meetings and then they
occasionally they do start yelling and
occasionally they do interrupt somebody
because you've got a third grade teacher
reading their kid basically pornography
and they're a little annoyed about it
but you see how they do that it's very
effective what they do I like civil
conversation I but I'm just not for
people who who yell and are mean and
things of that nature well you know
people might start getting mean when say
their border is being overrun and their
towns are being destroyed right you
might be a little annoyed if you're a
Border Town in Texas right you might be
a little annoyed if you're one of the
teachers or one of the parents of a kid
who has I don't know maybe been being
called the opposite gender by their
teacher and hiding it for six months you
might be a little annoyed but as long as
we do this Sibley right it's civilly
okay but you guys know it's not just
about the border and it's not just about
racism uh and gender and all that the
new one that they are really moving on
us like this is the next covid this is
where the next lockdowns are going to
come the rest of it is climate and the
people you know they love this word
intersectionality this is where they can
combine a whole bunch of his perceived
depressions or perceived problems they
can combine them into one massive
Transformer Juggernaut uh to scare the
hell out of everybody so now they also
want to combine climate with race yes
this is a real one believe it or not and
if we're talking race and people who are
lying about race well then obviously I
have to show you a video of Al Sharpton
over at the televised mental institution
known as MSNBC uh he had climatologists
this guy I think has been debunked
several times but he's I suppose he is a
climate scientist I had him on the show
maybe about 10 years ago by the name of
Michael Mann he's the one that came up
with the hockey stick theory that one
day we were just gonna like flip the
switch or the the Earth the atmosphere
would flip the switch and we'd go from
being fine to being destroyed by climate
change it kind of has never come to
fruition of course but anyway
uh he went on Al Sharpton's show and
they talked about how climate change is
actually racist in various communities
that there's more impact than others
because they're closer to certain things
in the community I've I've raised issues
about uh the green movement and some
blacks say well that's not our issue
when it's more about issue than others
how do we deal with breaking the
messaging down whether you're black or
other if people understand this is about
them this is not just something they're
watching on the news about Maori yeah
thanks Reverend it's good to be with you
and it's such an important point I live
in Philadelphia if ever there was a city
where we can witness the you know the
the tremendous Injustice associated with
these extreme weather events wrought by
climate change it's Philadelphia the
extreme flooding that we witness in the
wake of Hurricane Ida a couple years ago
of course it was Frontline communities
it was minority communities who felt the
brunt of that the urban heat Islands it
turns out that redlining was done in
such a way in the past so that the areas
that are primarily minority populations
are subject to the worst Urban heat
island effects in the summer and so
there is a tremendous climate Justice
component
we just had a debate as to whether I
could call that guy what I wanted to
call them but we're just we're not going
to do it you know the whole the whole
world is coming after uh Rumble right
now and I know Rumble obviously would
never kick me off but YouTube could just
take me out at any moment at this point
right they're going after Russell you
guys get it these people like this has
nothing to do hurricane I had a couple
years ago it had there was some flooding
involved with that and obviously that
affected black people there is one black
guy that I'm freaking out about related
to climate change and and hopefully
maybe we could start a GoFundMe or
something uh but Barack Obama guys he
lives on 30 Acres on the water in
Martha's Vineyard and and climate change
is a common and we must save Barack
Obama I don't whatever we have to do I
will do a fundraiser I'll do like a
Jerry Lewis Telethon I mean 24 hours
I'll bring in the animals we'll bring in
some of my celebrity friends and we must
raise money so that Barack Obama can
leave his 30-acre mansion on Martha's
Vineyard because the water is coming and
maybe he could move to downtown Philly
uh where you know yes I understand
that's also at risk of hurricanes and
whatever but he'd be a little safer I
mean the idea that you live in
Philadelphia try to you we've shown you
videos of Philadelphia Philadelphia is
like if you if San Francisco is the top
of the zombie apocalypse Billy's
probably like number seven right you can
throw a Portland Seattle parts of LA
something like that but Philly is is
absolute disaster you know in the post
game show let's find one of the
compilations of Philly just melting down
with homelessness and drugs and
everything else but the point is climate
there is literally nobody in Philly
wandering around going climate change is
the problem here but they want to scare
them into thinking that it's the problem
right you have a much bigger worry
whether you should go to Pats or Gino's
to get your cheese steak if you live in
Philly then then climate change you
ridiculous person but okay let's
continue on the climate change thing
they are trying to freak you out this
video is really going viral over the
weekend there is a British Wildlife TV
presenter
by the name of Chris Pac-Man he's on
channel four in the UK and he put this
video out himself uh prepping the people
because uh he's thinking about breaking
the law to save the climate it's
absolutely incredible this guy he's a
true hero go it's time to make up my own
mind
and decide if I think it's time to break
the law
what are we going to do about it
[Music]
an overwhelming number of people
recognize that we are in danger they
fear for their amongst their children
fighting for the future of life on Earth
no government no major political party
has
significantly addressed the issue we
haven't been listening to us the climate
activists now I'm not asking for anyone
to break the law there are so many
lawful ways to get involved Raise Your
Voice post a poster sign a potential
Banner go on a March Lobby your local MP
however for me myself when significant
and obvious danger so
but I've got to raise my voice
if you're an activist
that's already made a decision that yes
you're going to break the law so long as
no one is hurt
and there's no lasting environmental
damage
then you'll have my support and
personally
I think
I've reached a point where I now
consider it the ethically responsible
thing to do
all right first up did you guys note how
many times he touched his face in the
middle of that thing you know the thing
that I reference all the time there's an
episode of Seinfeld where Jerry's
talking about how when you're lying to
somebody you touch your face and that's
like the tell that you're lying somebody
in the higher up on your face that you
touch if you're scratching your head
while you're telling someone something
that means you're like seriously lying
remember James Clapper the former CIA
director under oath when they were like
are our intelligence Services uh spying
on the American people and he's
scratching his head and he's like not
wittingly it's like this guy can't stop
touching his face okay first off okay
congratulations if you live in the UK or
I guess anywhere else because that video
did go viral he's got your back if you
break the law that'll help
um also there's nothing you could do the
weather's not coming for you it's morons
like this who are trying to use you
that's what it is but I think we decided
that uh during the afternoon today when
I have a little bit of a break I'm gonna
go out because I have a backyard here
with some trees so a similar background
is that and I'm gonna get out there and
Connor we can do some sort of soft
camera thing like yeah there's yeah we
have all the camera stuff available to
us and I'll touch my face a lot and I'm
going to basically just take that script
we'll get the actual script and I'm just
going to talk about taxes because I
don't like taxes and if you're gonna
break the low because of Texas then I'll
be here for you I'll save you if you
don't want the IRS to come to your house
like what what what
that actually would make far more sense
right like I don't want my I don't want
my tax dollars funding award in Ukraine
and I'll help you with the IRS comes to
arrest you
all right speaking of lunatics and crazy
people Hillary Clinton's back baby uh
because we are getting into an election
year so she's got to come back she's got
to scare us about Trump and election
integrity and the rest of it I did not
know that Hillary Clinton had a podcast
but apparently uh she does I guess there
are more podcasts than people at this
point tweet from Hillary Clinton
I'm thrilled to kick off my season four
uh season four of my podcast you and me
both with someone I'm a huge fan of
democratic house leader representative
Jeffries Hakeem Jeffries that is from
Hip Hop to civil service and Criminal
Justice Reform to Congress we got deep
into what makes this young leader tick
and how he envisions the future of the
Democrat Party subscribe to today on
blah blah blah you'll get the okay
Zippity Dippity uh why am I bringing
this up that Hillary Clinton has a
podcast well it's one it's that I'm
giving you a warning not to listen to it
or you can downvote it or whatever you
got to do in Spotify because you know
they promote the hell out of her right
whatever YouTube and the rest of us the
rest of those things are doing to guys
like me they're doing the reverse to her
they want you to see that all the time
anywho uh Hillary was interviewed she's
making the rounds on the media again and
she was asked you know why why is it
that people don't seem to like uh Kamala
Harris and you're not gonna believe what
she said
you know there has been more talk at
least in my time in politics about
questioning whether the Vice President
should be on the ticket I know what I
think that's about but I want to know
what you think that's about well I think
it's about uh you know a number of
things I think vice presidents are
either never thought about or they're an
afterthought
um and it's a tough position to be in no
matter who you are but I also think that
she's a first I mean she's the first
woman she's the first woman of color
she's the first daughter of immigrants I
mean you can go on down the list and uh
so there will definitely be a lot more
scrutiny uh than as usual for a vice
president
all right first off there's no way she's
the first daughter of immigrants right
like that we had a founding of the
country through somebody came here from
somewhere like all right that's number
one second and also like I didn't I
actually didn't even know that I don't
even know where her parents I'm not even
sure where her parents are from it's
actually completely irrelevant and I
didn't know if they were first
generation immigrants or second
generation immigrants but the idea that
there's someone at home like watching a
video of of her talking with the
circular logic and you know Russia big
Ukraine's all the nonsense that are and
they're like you know what I don't like
that that daughter of immigrants like
it's just so stupid and of course it has
nothing to do with her being a woman and
it has nothing to do with her being
black or or whatever she is nobody cares
about any of that stuff anymore okay
everyone thinks she's an idiot because
she is not particularly bright she comes
up as deeply inauthentic her laughs
scares children those are the main
reasons that people don't like her and
she just seems like a really just
dishonest actor so it's perfect that's
gen sake and really think about what
passes as journalism on MSNBC Jen saki
who worked for the Biden Administration
where Hillary uh for the Biden
Administration who Joe Biden was the VP
under Obama and Hillary was the
Secretary of State under Obama like it's
just a big circle jerk
all right I'm not even going to say what
I was going to say there but the point
is just watching this video with sake
and Hillary because they're back on
Russia collusion
Vladimir Putin has obviously your friend
your friend in mine he has uh intervened
in our election in the past right it's
not something as you experience
firsthand it's not something we talk
about a lot do you fear that that is
something that could be happening for
2024 and do you think we should be
talking about it more well I think we
should be talking about it more because
I don't think despite all of the uh you
know deniers uh there's any doubt that
he interfered in our election or that he
has interfered in many ways in uh the uh
Internal Affairs of other countries
funding political parties funding you
know political candidates uh buying off
uh you know government officials in
different places
sounds like a lot of that we do in
America buying off people influence blah
blah blah okay so apparently we're
allowed to talk about an election denial
again so if you just track what
Hillary's saying what Hillary's
basically arguing is what the Democrats
have argued for a long time somehow
Putin stole the election for Trump the
first one then he just decided not to do
it again this time but now we should be
watching out again because it could
happen
it's so insane people were demonetized
kicked off Twitter and YouTube and
everywhere else for even questioning
election results and now you have a
former Secretary of State former Senator
wannabe president who knows maybe she'll
get back in the running like once Joe's
out which I think we're looking at a
couple months at this point and it does
seem like it's going to be Newsom who
knows maybe she'll get back involved and
here she is basically pushing a
conspiracy theory a conspiracy theory
which by the way LED to two failed
impeachments and you get the rest of it
anyway I've mentioned not these a couple
times show and I have to say this next
segment is very refreshing for me
because usually when we're talking about
Nazis these days we're talking about
just regular people you know what I mean
we're talking about someone says oh
that's a Nazi over there and you go oh
well what makes them well they think
boys or boys and girls or girls you go
boy the Nazis really ain't what they
used to be so it's very refreshing on
this show when I'm able to talk about a
Nazi and go that's an actual value oh
and speaking of Nazis uh we watch the
the new Indiana Jones movie over the
weekend it wasn't terrible I was shocked
it we finished it and I go that wasn't
terrible which is all I asked from a
movie these days anyway an actual Nazi
showed up in Canada so first I want to
show you a tweet and an image from uh
Ian Haworth he's been on the show once
or twice uh this is he grabbed a
political headline so look at this Nazi
linked veteran received Ovation during
zelenski's Canada visit and his comment
was quite clever so when they call them
conservatives conservatives are Nazis
right but when it's an actual Nazi the
headline reads Nazi linked veteran yes
this guy is an actual Nazi so here's
just a little bit more
about zielinski showing up at Canadian
Parliament and you're a slab hunk the
actual Ukrainian Nazi here's a bit more
and then I'll add some context after
solenski's speech received at least a
dozen standing ovations
there was also one for this man a 98
year old Ukrainian Canadian who fought
for Ukrainian Independence against the
Russians during the second World War
go so that guy who fought or Ukrainian
Independence against the Russians or he
must be great he's old now too he must
be great well a little context uh this
is from uh CPAC meet Yara slav hunk hunk
is a Nazi who fought with the 14th
division of the Waffen SS against the
Russians in Ukraine in World War II hunk
assisted in the systemic extermination
of Ukraine's Jewish population and
installation of a Nazi dictator in the
region hunk also engaged in the
wholesale Slaughter of Ukrainian people
and entire Villages disloyal to Hitler
so that's the guy that Justin Trudeau
decided to honor at Canadian Parliament
and got repeated standing ovations well
then of course as you can guess the wise
people of the internet rise up and they
start clipping it and finding out more
information about this guy and oh maybe
Trudeau you shouldn't be honoring Nazis
I know yesterday was also Yom Kippur
which is the holiest day in the in the
Jewish year you know timing timing man
you know if you're going to honor a Nazi
you honor them you know middle of
October nothing's happening you know you
hire him right before Halloween Maybe
anyway then of course the pushback comes
and then suddenly Trudeau did realize
that maybe honoring a Nazi wasn't the
best thing although his uh explanation
and apology here is as disingenuous as
everything else he does
obviously it's extremely upsetting that
this happened uh the speeder speaker has
acknowledged his mistake and is
apologized but this is something that is
deeply embarrassing to the parliament of
Canada and by extension to all Canadians
I think particularly of Jewish MPS and
all members of the Jewish Community
across the country who are celebrating
young or commemorating Yom Kippur today
I think it's going to be really
important that all of us push back
against Russian propaganda Russian
disinformation and continue our
steadfast and unequivocal support for
Ukraine as we did last week with
announcing further measures to stand
with Ukraine in Russia's illegal war
against it
hate is not the word that I have for
that man we need a new word we need to
invent a word maybe it could be it could
sound a little French in honor of Canada
or honor of Montreal or something where
I could come up with a word to describe
him you guys can help us in the comments
somehow during Yom Kippur we should be
thinking about Russian propaganda and
funding the Ukraine where I can tell you
as I was at my sisters yesterday with
the kids and we were all around the
table and we fasted all day very very
hungry it's about 8 P.M sun going down
and we were starving all spreads right
in front of us the bagels the locks the
cream cheese all of it I kept saying
guys guys let's let's not eat just yet
could we just figure out a way to give a
little more money to Ukraine right now
that's what today is really about right
the day of atonement when we really
should be thinking about what we've done
in this past year and was it good and
can we do better in the next year I said
put that aside your own personal
problems for just that that hey you over
there put down the egg salad we must
fund Ukraine and stop the Russian
Prophet no you got it anyway uh what
else is going on with Ukraine these days
it's not just that we are funding the
war everyone knows that we're funding a
war which you might argue if you're
funding the war if you're paying for the
war maybe that means you're in the war
but we've never actually got an
authorization for this war our leaders
leaders keep telling us that this is the
most important thing in town Mitch
McConnell loves this thing Biden loves
this thing there's few things that bring
these people together more than War well
it turns out
guys you're gonna be very excited about
this as good taxpayers uh it's not just
that we're funding the War uh we're
funding far more than that uh and even
now 60 Minutes is covering it which
tells you this thing might actually be
bursting forth into the mainstream now
American taxpayers are financing more
than just weapons we discovered the US
government's buying seeds and fertilizer
for Ukrainian farmers
and covering the salaries of Ukraine's
First Responders all 57 000 of them that
includes the team that trains this
rescue dog named joy to comb through the
wreckage of Russian strikes looking for
survivors
and the U.S also funds the divers who we
saw clearing unexploded ammunition from
the country's rivers to make them safe
again for swimming and fishing
Russia's Invasion shrank Ukraine's
economy by about a third we were
surprised to find that to keep it afloat
the U.S government is subsidizing small
businesses awesome dudes we're
subsidizing small businesses in Ukraine
sure here if you have a small business
we'll shut you down and you can only go
to big box stores but in Ukraine we'll
fund your little operation man why why
did I do that accent
I don't know where that came from
that whole you that whole Yom Kippur
stopped the ukrainians thing from
Trudeau really got me anyway if you want
something sensible rather than me
talking like this about Ukraine uh
here's Rand Paul about what's actually
happening in Ukraine
there's also this incredible story about
an American journalist Gonzalo Mira he's
reportedly right now in prison in
Ukraine on allegations of of spreading
Russian propaganda I I don't understand
this that Joe Biden could approve 113
billion dollars of money to Ukraine and
yet he has not tried to get this
American journalist out of prison there
how is that possible
it's even worse than that Maria they've
canceled the elections what kind of
democracy has no election so next year
zielinski said he's not going to have an
election because it would be
inconvenient during the war and would be
expensive well the thing is if you don't
have elections why in the world would be
supporting a country that's not a
democracy they banned the political
parties they've invaded churches they've
arrested priests so no it isn't a
democracy it's a corrupt regime and are
the Russians any better no the Russians
are worse but at the same time we don't
always have to pick some side to be on
but the ultimate reason I'm against this
is we don't have the money and when we
borrow more money it leads to more
inflation leads to moral likelihood of
recession in our country and so we just
can't keep doing it man it's so freaking
refreshing when you hear someone tell
the truth right like you feel that
you're listening to him and you're like
oh uh I don't have to contort and I
don't feel weird like when you're
hearing lies all the time like you we
have a built-in system
that that detects lives right it is it
is ages old it is deeply built into us
and that's why there are so many lies
these days and so many people so many
people's lie detectors seems to have
been blown apart but when you hear the
truth I mean notice Rand Paul doesn't
have to scream like Neil deGrasse Tyson
in the earlier segment he doesn't
because he's not he's not making up
nonsense to make you feel better he's
telling you what the truth is boy you
know we've got the zelenski guy they're
canceling elections they're arresting
people you know this idea of canceling
elections during wartime that that's
kind of okay or basically is okay in
Ukraine wouldn't that be the greatest
signal right now to think that uh they
will escalate this thing into World War
III right before our elections so that
maybe we don't have to have elections
wouldn't that be something like am I is
that Alex Jones level crazy where it's
like oh well that democracy doesn't have
to have elections zielinski is a really
great guy and he's dealing with
something really crazy with that Putin
and the Russians
well wait a minute if that thing
escalates why would we have elections
right like these people are just out of
control but beyond all of the the Nuance
on the ground and what we're finding and
all that that we don't have the money we
simply don't have the money the hundred
what was it 113 Bill the 113 bill you
think maybe we could use that I mean we
don't even have it in the first place
right we borrow that money in the first
place but let's pretend we wanted to use
that 113 bill you maybe could do
something with it you probably could do
something there's something there's got
to be something you could do with it you
could build better Railways right
remember you know Cali's dumped like
what how many billion into their failed
Railway which by the way just a couple
days ago free state of Florida we
officially have the bright line here
it'll take you from Orlando all the way
down to Miami couple stops three hours
gorgeous brand new I think I'm gonna try
to take it after an event I do in
Orlando next week anywho the point is we
don't even have the freaking money for
this but if we did we could use it on
our border but they'll also tell you
that the Border isn't a problem I
believe we have a compilation of
Democrats lying through their teeth
which is just as porous as our border it
is my testimony that the order is secure
we have
a secure border
in that that is a priority for Any
Nation including ours in our
Administration we have taken
unprecedented action over the past year
and a half to secure our border and we
have a process in place to manage
migrants of the Border we're working to
make sure it's safe and orderly and
Humane the border is closed we agree
that the border is secure we're
executing a comprehensive strategy to
secure our borders one of our highest
priorities is to ensure that we have a
secure border and that is what we are
doing the border is secure all right you
get it we can show you a million of
those and you don't even need the
compilations to get it like RFK has been
out there we've shown you videos of
people just literally wandering through
and then they they let 10 people and
then they close the door they wait for a
minute they let another attend we showed
you the one guy last week the guy gets
into America and he's like he walks up
to the Border region he's like hey can I
go to Chicago and it's like dude you're
in San Diego stay in San Diego you're
going to get shot he's probably dead at
this point but like it's all just insane
these people lie about everything and of
course if I'm talking about Liars we
must show you a clip of cringe
Jean-Pierre answering or actually not
answering a question from Fox news's
Peter Ducey what do you call
them people illegally cross the border
in a single day so what do you call it
Peter when GOP puts forth a wait no no
no no no no no no no you can't I'm
answering okay
okay no no no we're moving on the
background
no no I tried to answer Peter I tried to
answer the question you stopped me let's
go okay God she's she's just terrible at
her job put aside anything else you
think of her she's just terrible at her
job it is a completely legitimate
question what do you guys call it what
do you call it when we see all these
people invading the country and then she
starts going on about the GOP the GOP is
not in charge of the border the
president is in charge of the Border
it's on that very short list of what
that brain adult fool is supposed to do
and he's not I can't even say he's not
doing it they are intentionally doing
this but she tries to turn into the GOP
and he's like no no no no I'm not gonna
have it and then she just moves on
because she has no answer and I would
just like to say for the record and for
you freaks over at Media Matters who are
watching the show right now my criticism
of her has nothing to do with the fact
that she's black or a chick or a lesbo
those are all great things those are
spectacular wonderful things and she
should be credited accordingly my
criticism of her is because she is a
horrible White House spokesperson or a
Administration that is a complete
embarrassment but things that aren't
embarrassment how about this we've got a
governor here in Florida who in effect
is acting like the president and taking
care of Florida the way that a president
should take care of his Nation uh
DeSantis tweeted this out this is Biden
Border in this Biden border Invasion has
led to asinine ideas like giving illegal
aliens ID cards and allowing blanket
work waivers to those coming here
illegally and there you can see those
are what the ID cards look like so you
get in you are by definition breaking
the law they will give you an ID card
and somehow allow you to work you know
last week we played you a clip of AOC
that that wizard AOC where she was in
New York City saying you know we have to
help these people get jobs and I was
very critical of that because no we
don't we have to figure out who they are
and if you came in illegally you gotta
go we can figure out what the margin
cases are and all of that stuff fine we
really can right and if you've been here
for a long time and you've been working
and a good citizen we can discuss all of
that stuff but all of these new people
10 000 people who are coming to New York
City every month over running the
services and all that so anyway I was
very critical of AOC on that and I and I
saw a couple comments people saying no
Dave if they're here just get them the
work waiver and it's like no you CA you
cannot do that it doesn't even if we had
a true labor shortage which we don't
have but even if we did you cannot
encourage bad behavior do you know that
there are people right now right now on
lists trying to get into the United
States legally for whatever reason and
they just get pushed further and further
and further further back and by the way
the United States doesn't have to let
anyone in we are a nation of immigrants
and that's what we were set up for but
we've got some housekeeping to do I
think to figure this stuff out
anyway they just want to have the whole
system destroyed and it's not just the
politicians and uh the the people and
the Border people and all that who are
trying to do it right it's not it's also
they are aided and abetted by our
quote-unquote journalists and here is
quote-unquote journalist from uh CNN Jim
Acosta we haven't shown a Jim Acosta
video in a while
he had a North Carolina representative
Ralph of Ralph Norman on Republican to
discuss what's going on at the border
and you tell me is Jim Acosta doing
journalism here or is he doing partisan
hackery go
it just sounds like you're throwing uh
rhetoric around with no basis in fact
no you can have you been to the Border
of course I have
you seen what's going on the rapes the
uh it's open I mean nobody can can deny
that the borders and uh they've got it's
a crisis
well I'll ask the question sir and the
boys are not open that is that is
something that that is uh peddled as a
talking point but it's not true there
are fences there are walls uh there are
border patrol agents who work on the
border
the five plus million uh that have
gotten in this country illegally uh is
not a figment of our imagination ask the
border patrol agents ask anybody down
there they're frozen I guess I haven't
you you have not been able to answer my
question as to how you effectively do
border enforcement if you're shutting
down the government I guess but I guess
we're not going to get an answer to that
question I don't know how to say it
anymore plainly guys there is a giant
system in place to make us all
and it is your job as a human being not
to buy the BS it really is everything
the Costa says there again he's not a
journalist does Acosta not know that
they're letting people right through the
Border uh in acosta's own City I believe
CNN where he is is in New York City in
that City he's got the mayor saying our
city is about to collapse because of ten
thousand illegal immigrants a day a
month so how is it that they're getting
there unless the border is open like
this is basic stuff everything is do and
also he's like well we have we have a
wall and fence oh did you just come out
for Trump's wall because I remember when
Trump wanted a wall you were calling him
race this that was the whole modus
operandi of CNN are you suddenly for
walls and by the way not only do we not
have walls and fences everywhere but if
you open the door of a fence people
sometimes wander in and we've shown you
those videos too so here's the beauty
guys here's the beauty now we're
bringing this thing around the American
people and not just the American people
people all over the world are not buying
this nonsense anymore there are enough
people who are telling the truth
thankfully we have to whatever degree of
a free internet that we have at least at
the moment and people are seeing what
the truth is they're not only seeing
what the truth is at the border they're
seeing what the truth is in terms of
their kids being abused in essence at
schools but they are seeing how evil the
media has become you may remember last
week we showed you a couple clips of
Dave Portnoy from Barstool Sports he had
advanced warning that a hit piece was
coming out against him like an absolute
just Hatchet job hit piece and of course
that's what they do right that's what
they do against me it's what they do
against anyone who's outside of the the
let's say their Overton window and and I
would say really in competition with
them right why was CNN always going
after Rogan you get it because he was
bigger than CNN anyway
here is Portnoy on Fox News talking to
uh Jesse Waters uh going after the
activist not journalist at the
Washington Post in the New York Times
where they don't just want to disagree
with you or resent you because your bro
your Friday whatever they want to
destroy your entire Enterprise They want
to destroy the people you're giving
money to charity to they want to take
down your sponsors they want all your
employees fired what brought that from
here to here
I think journalism has become activism
really uh they're not looking for the
truth the ironic thing and you alluded
to it for this pizza Festival
like the very people who are now trying
to threaten these pizzerias and be like
you were going to write a hit piece and
Associate you with this bad person they
are all fighting to shut these people
down two years ago they didn't want them
open I'm the one who was fighting to
keep them open raise money keep small
business and then they turn around to
these very people that we're trying to
help save and say you shouldn't do
business with them it really they have
become activists there's not an ounce of
Journalism I watched the Walter Cronkite
piece that you played in the beginning
of this segment there's no interest in
telling both sides of the story ever I
have been the subject of so many hit
pieces and I have started so many times
cordially let me tell my side of the
story your facts are off if anybody with
an open mind who hasn't made their
judgment who listens to both sides this
guy is not who are portraying them okay
so so you guys get it right like you get
it everything he said there was right
these people people are activists they
lie I've been through this so many times
Rogan's been through it Peterson's been
through it Andrew Tate's been through it
so many rumbles going through it right
now but the real reason they're going
after him is not because they think he's
a misogynist and a racist and that's
going to destroy the pizza Community the
guy's raised incredible amounts of money
for small businesses and everything else
it's because bar stool Sports which he
grew basically himself right is now
worth
550 million dollars
that's what upsets them he is outside of
their Control building something that
people actually care about it's not
fully my thing like I don't even know
that I've ever been to the website but
like I can respect the grind and I can
respect people who who build good things
right and that's why they are going
after him and the other piece of this
and now this is so beautiful this is so
beautiful this will make your Tuesday
wonderful
is that the BS layer from the
politicians and the media people is
being chipped away at right and where is
it being chipped away at a bunch of the
people that I've referenced several
times on the show but it's it's the
rogans Peterson's Shapiro's it's all of
the online people they're chipping away
at the nonsense and they're waking
people up you don't have to agree with
everything I say but to some extent
people that watch this show whatever
people are just kind of waking up to the
nonsense so this is absolutely
incredible this is a tweet an image from
kennicoa the great this is just so
absolutely Spectacular from Bloomberg
News Gavin Newsom is worried about
misinformation and micro Cults online
because his son is asking him about
Andrew Tate Jordan Peterson and Joe
Rogan Newsome I really worry about these
micro Cults my kids are in the governor
told Bloomberg I say microcult
microcults because I don't know if
there's a better way to describe it my
son is asking me about Andrew 8 Jordan
Peterson and then immediately he's
talking about Joe Rogan and I'm like
here it is the pathway
coming for you gav
in the gate to hell is open it goes
right through me you understand how
great is that like like Gavin newsom's
son might be watching this show right
now I might have been the the pill that
brought him to Jordan Peterson and
Andrew Tate and Joe Rogan like how cool
is that Gavin Newsom Evil Lizard snake
vile cold blooded psychopath Gavin
Newsom his son is waking up to his
but what he's really telling
you Gavin Newsome as he's prepping to
run for president is that he is trying
to figure out how are we going to take
out these micro Cults this guy is deeply
calculated so his move there will be
we'll have to figure out how to work
with big Tech to take them out because
they're going after my son but sorry
buddy the truth is incontrovertible and
uh that your son is waking up right now
by the way speaking of Gavin Newsom son
I'm sure he's a great kid his son went
to basketball camp where they didn't
have to wear masks while Gavin was
blocking everybody else down so that's
not a shot at his son and and the
Newsome child if you're watching this
program you're a great kid keep at it
brother you're on your way it's great
but people are not buying the nonsense
from the Democrats anymore yes they
figure out ways to win elections but
more and more people are waking up to
the BS and more and more people are
waking up to the fact that Biden is just
you know a sack there ain't much there
there ain't much left they're figuring
it out patience on that but here's some
new polling on what's going on with
Biden and his you know how he's handling
pretty much everything
overwhelmingly say they are not feeling
good about the economy and that the
president is to blame just 30 percent
approve of his performance on the
economy a career low largely dragged
down by pocketbook issues for families
74 of the country there's about three
quarters of Americans who say the
economy is either not so good or
downright poor a 23 approve of his
handling of the situation another career
my God people might start turning to
micro Cults they've so had it with this
Biden and his economy and the
immigration thing and everything else
they're turning to Jordan Peterson we
must save Gavin newsom's son great kid
dude great kid
so what should we strive for guys we can
either believe the acostas who are liars
we can believe the sakees and the
Hillary clintons and the Gavin newsoms
we can believe the an entire machine
designed to make a stupid and behave and
bow to it or we can figure out the
little spots the little spots where we
are empowering ourselves and uh Tucker
Carlson had a nice little speech on what
do Americans really want
their own
copying lectured or hurt in an
environment that uplifts rather than
degrades in a place that is clean rather
than filthy orally rather than chaotic
that's what human beings want in every
culture in Africa Asia Australia in
every place around the world because
it's not a cultural desire it's an
innate human desire and any government
that takes that into account and tries
to achieve it should be proud of what
it's doing the people who live there
should be grateful and they should not
allow the people who have mismanaged the
rest of the world to tell them otherwise
period
so stay proud of what you have I'm sorry
for talking so fast God bless you
yeah it's just true it's nice to see
Tucker fired up like that occasionally
but it is just true we have a series of
people a managerial class that is just
doing everything wrong and spitting in
our face when we do it and then we have
this other series of people that are
figuring it out right and and by the way
you guys watching this right now I know
how many of you over the three four
years since kobit started how many of
you moved you picked up and moved or how
many of you woke up to what was really
going on or you decided to get out of a
sea got our Founders were wise enough to
come up with this Federalist system and
there will be places where it's
basically oh is not okay but you will
have to figure out how to operate within
that so that you can have those things
that as Tucker says are in things that
as Tucker says are innate to Being Human
you want a place where it's safe to
raise a family right you want to say a
place where it's safe to hand down
whatever traditions and culture you have